an unexpected thriller is heating up
netflix's top ten
offering to the storm a spanish german
production recently made its way onto
the streamer's list of most watched
movies the atmospheric supernaturally
tinged spanish language thriller managed
to crack the list during a weekend
dominated by the high-profile netflix
originals the kissing boot 2 and the
charlize theron starring comic
adaptation the old guard
while offering to the storm doesn't
offer a ton of faces that would be super
familiar to american audiences that only
helps to ground the creepy action
as do the naturalistic performances of
its cast marta atura a veteran spanish
actress who has been a fixture on the
big screen in that country for the
better part of two decades leads the
film as police inspector amaya salazar
amaya returns to her hometown of bostan
in the basque country an autonomous
community in spain to get to the bottom
of some strange goings-on
there amaya also confronts demons from
her own past
the movie benefits from the fact that
the basque country which straddles
spain's border with france is an
incredibly scenic region with rolling
hills and picturesque villages
offering to the storm suggests that the
area's old world charm hides a kind of
dark secrets that may have to do with
the ancient supernatural entities of
local folklore that are said to inhabit
the region's many forests
the area can practically be seen as
another character in its own right
which certainly seems to be the
intention of author dolores redondo who
wrote the novel upon which the film is
based and who grew up in the area
if you're taken in by offering to the
storm's brooding atmosphere and twisty
narrative but find that some of the plot
points seem to come out of nowhere well
there's a reason for that
the movie is actually the conclusion to
a much longer story
offering to the storm is the third and
final film in the bostan trilogy
all based on redondo's novels which
began with 2017's the invisible guardian
that flick tells the story of amaya
salazar's first return to her old
stomping grounds to help solve the
ritualistic serial slayings of several
local teens
while also locking horns with her sister
and her abusive nursing home bound
mother
the film ends with the revelation that
amaya and her american husband james are
expecting a child
the story continued in 2019's the legacy
of the bones which begins after amaya
has given birth to a baby boy
when a number of people in boston begin
dying by suicide amaya returns to
investigate quickly finding that the
death seemed to be suspiciously linked
to the series of killings that she had
solved in the first film
while offering to the storm certainly
works as a standalone movie some of its
character interactions that seem laden
with meaning and callbacks to previous
events
will make a bit more sense if you've
seen the first two flicks fortunately
they're both available for streaming on
netflix so you can binge watch the
entire trilogy
reviews for offering to the storm have
been quite positive with a number of
critics noting that fans of the genre
will want to check it out and stream the
invisible guardian and the legacy of the
bones beforehand so they get the full
picture
that said critics have also pointed out
that viewers may be able to predict some
of the twist and might be hesitant to
dive in due to the movie's 139 minute
run time but that should not deter them
from giving this well-received movie a
shot
as tequila wrote in their review of the
flick offering to the storm is a
thrilling ride with enough to make it a
good and horrifying watch
if the runtime does not daunt you i'd
suggest giving this one a go but do
check out the previous installments a
movie marathon might be a good idea
you can figure stuff out before the big
reveal is made though and the police as
per usual make some flawed decisions
however all in all a decent and
thrilling watch if you're sold on
offering to the storm stream it and its
predecessors too
on netflix now check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one